Jacqueline Jacqueline please don't do
this
Jacqueline Jacqueline please don't do
this listen Germaine you had your chance
baby please I'll change listen honey it
is too late what do you mean
yeah what's good to me Ramona the names
Tod Tod No
who is this are you kidding me this guy
yeah Jackie told me so much about you
Jackie Jacqueline come on I've been
trying to make that a thing for years
yeah but it just sounds so much better
when it comes out of Todd's mouth Jackie
is telling me you used to play baseball
I guess and the minors yeah you look
like you got a gun on you huh were you a
pitcher used to throw that heat wait
what do you do are you charming me Todd
stop just stop
Todd is very charming and he's a real
man who knows how to treat a real woman
what's that even mean well he's also
really really good at massages so like
how good can it oh there you go gosh I
went to massage therapy school part-time
when I was training to become a
firefighter you have some knots in you
oh that's really admirable Todd hey
thanks for saying that j-town okay don't
don't Nick named him well maybe you'll
like say if you like j-town j-town I
love that that's very cool yeah okay me
and Todd are going to live a wonderful
life we would be happy without you come
on Todd I think that's my cue to leave
you know she gets your bad hey before
you go ah that's one ring are you in
musical theater at all I tend to dabble
in the theatrical arts okay cuz I just
have to free wicked tickets now you know
now that ol jacqueline's gone I was
wondering if maybe you wicked yeah I'd
love to see how that's been sold out for
ages of course okay stop it
okay listen honey Jermaine I love you
this is my friend Todd from pottery
class and he agreed to help me make you
jealous but it's you that I want this
was all an elaborate plan honey I'm fine
and all but Todd here this is this is
who you should be with he's look at him
oh look at this guy
he's a man amongst boys a king amongst
peasants Hey
don't sell yourself short j-town he was
kind you're smart
it was important that's absolutely
beautiful no it's not beautiful honey
it's a line from the help featuring
Octavia Spencer okay he's charming you
that's what he does listen Jackie I'm
beginning to think you don't want me to
be happy at all please that's why I'm
leaving you honey what and I'm taking
Todd here with me
guys Jermaine can't I'd expect a magic
touch